des princes juste à côté des dieux des
studios de tp on en a profité pour
demander à andreas voilà le retourne
andreas notre envoyé spécial de se
rendre sur place et d'aller un peu
taquiné les supporters ont leur à son
thé pmp regarde bonjour quand tu
t'appelles jérémy fabrique bons
supporters de paris je suppose bien sûr
vous allez au match souvent way souvent
pour me donner un petit peu de voix pour
le magnéto la parcelle marseille autant
trouver qui jouent comme des gros ce
cher c'est des gros rat sa mère wes
ennuis commençaient face avant avec un
mais calmez vous fait un bon match on
entend marcher longtemps mais la pilule
mais paris bien sûr pour paris viii est
ce que vous pensez de m
mais plus la mer mais l'om c'est
clairement mon en bas il est à chier
alors ça et marseille
[Musique]
vidéo si marseille tu connais un peu les
champs collectifs ultra paris forcément
tu peux m'en faire un petit allez allez
et le psg allait
ne jamais rien lâcher toujours encouragé
[Applaudissements]